on ne l'avait pas vu depuis 24 heures et
chose rare le président américain
portait un masque
c'est par mesure d' extrême précaution
dit la maison blanche que dans notre
chemin passera quelques jours à
l'hôpital militaire walter reed en
banlieue de washington
le président est fatigués fait un peu de
fièvre a dit son médecin
je pense que je vais très bien dit il
dans une vidéo qu'il a publié sur
twitter non va en être sûr son chef de
cabinet marc madiot en point de presse à
l'extérieur de la maison blanche s'était
voulu rassurant ce poste croate
les symptômes du président sont très
légers dit il est toujours aussi
dynamique
sa première question ce matin était
comment se porte l'économie
toujours est il que dans notre homme
fait partie des personnes à risque
il a 74 ans il est cliniquement obèses
et ferait un peu de pression artérielle
et ce qui choque surtout les américains
c'est que le président a poursuivi ses
activités jeudi alors que s'approche
conseillère robex venait de recevoir un
résultat positif à la coved 19 le
président est quand même à l'est il
devait être fonds au nude jose après
depuis cette nuit la maison blanche
s'active à retracer toute personne qui a
entré en contact avec le président ou sa
conseillère
nous prenons beaucoup de précaution dit
le sécrétaire d'état mike p o qui vient
de recevoir un résultat négatif pour la
co vide la maison blanche fait son
travail ajoutent ils
le sénateur républicain mike leigh et
cinq autres personnes ont été déclarés
positifs ils ont tous assisté samedi à
la nomination des milk en hibarette
comme juge de la cour suprême
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de la pandémie dans
notre champ pas toujours minimiser les
dangers du venus à cleveland il se
bloquait encore de joe biden parce
qu'ils portaient un masque
la guerre des miss et mister notre shop
a été maintes fois critiquée pour sa
gestion la pandémie le pays affiche plus
de 7 millions de cas et plus de deux
cent sept mille morts
le président américain a dû annuler tous
ses déplacements
désormais les rencontres seront virtuel
prévient son équipe joe biden aura eu le
dernier mot
aujourd'hui il a reçu un résultat
négatif il a rappelé à la population les
consignes de porter un masque et de
steve et les mains je ne tiens pas
quitter la maison blanche il ya quelques
heures pour l'hôpital joe biden continue
sa tournée au michigan
alors que le président américain entame
sa quarantaine ici assez beau de rigueur
qui sera du canada à washington